a few weeks ago I made a video about the
big Tech as I tend to do and somewhere
in the video I mentioned that Fang
Engineers generally have enough money to
retire by the time they're in their 30s
after all they tend to cross the 200 000
salary Mark pretty early in their career
and by the time they've been in the
workforce for 10 years their initial
stock compensation itself has grown 5 to
10 x so it doesn't take them long to
become a millionaire or even a
multi-millionaire to this an apple
engineer commented that retiring by 30
was the funniest line in the video he
went on to claim that he had been
working at Apple for almost 10 years now
and that he was nowhere near retirement
we had a bit of back and forth after
this but he eventually said this I'm not
a manager but I'm the highest tier of
software engineer just to give you a
sense of my total compensation I pay six
figures in federal taxes per year and I
still have to pay California tax on top
of that I'm a multi-millionaire I own a
house I own more than one million
dollars worth of Apple stock but here's
the thing it doesn't make me rich in
Silicon Valley I'm still a very much
middle class the cost of life is so high
it's probably easy to look at this and
be like oh it's just another
multi-millionaire complaining about how
they don't have enough money but I think
there's a lot more layers to this for
one I think this engineer is very much
genuine in that he doesn't feel
comfortable retiring in California even
with a multi-million dollar net worth
moreover statistically speaking Mega
millionaire really isn't all that
special nowadays in fact having a
million dollar net worth somehow doesn't
even get you into the top 10 of
households within America and that was
as of 2020. stocks have gone insane
since then and given that the wealthiest
10 of Americans own 89 of the market
they made a killing so being a
millionaire in 2023 may only put you
within the top 20 of Americans in other
words nearly one in five Americans are
from a million dollar household so join
me as we take a look at the history of
being a millionaire and why modern day
millionaires just don't feel the same
foreign
being a millionaire probably seems like
a super American capitalist ideology but
the term actually dates back to the
early 1700s to France though it did
involve America France was in a pretty
sticky financial situation at the time
as the probability of bankruptcy was
becoming larger and larger with each
passing day instead of just cutting back
on spending though the Duke of Orleans
decided that it would be a great idea to
embrace a more modern solution AKA take
on a bunch of debt essentially they
would open a sort of national bank and
to transfer all of their country's debt
to the bank and to pay back this debt
France was going to open up the
Mississippi Valley for trading and
Mining on paper this was a solid plan as
the Mississippi Valley was not only a
prime location but it was apparently
mineral rich not wanting to miss out the
French were to begin buying shares of
the Mississippi company like there was
no tomorrow sending the stock soaring
from 500 leaves to 18
000 liters as such many of these
investors would become extremely rich at
least on paper leading to the coining of
the term millionaire unfortunately this
High didn't last that long as the
Mississippi company's profits never
materialized and the stock would
collapse soon after since then we have
seen some references to the word
millionaire here and there from people
like Thomas Jefferson but the modern
capitalist millionaire didn't pop up
till the late 1800s during the Gilded
Age the Gilded Age was one of the most
prosperous times in U.S history at least
for the rich in fact the rich were
wealthier than ever far wealthier than
even the top billionaires today these
industrialists owned a massive oil
companies steel companies and Banks and
Automotive companies and these
businesses were so dominant that they
often controlled over 90 percent of
their respective Industries the owners
of these Mega monopolies were referred
to as millionaires but they weren't
really millionaires there weren't really
even billionaires their world was best
described in the trillions they
controlled the several percentage points
of the entire American GDP which
translates to each of them boasting net
worths of a quarter trillion or a half a
trillion so originally the term
millionaire wasn't used to describe
people with a million dollars per se
rather it was used to describe the Elon
musk's and the Jeff Bezos of the world
but the significance of the word
millionaire has only gone downhill since
then and it's easy to just point at
inflation and say that that's what
devalued millionaires but that's not
really the case a million 1880 is only
worth 30 million today not hundreds of
billions so the culprit isn't inflation
it's actually economic growth back in
the late 1800s the US didn't measure GDP
but it's estimated to be somewhere
between 10 and 20 billion today the
American GDP stands at 26.5 trillion or
1000 to 2 000 times more so really
whenever you see the word millionaire
back in the late 1800s and early 1900s
you can just replace it with the word
billionaire because that's really what
being a millionaire originally was
foreign
ly becoming a millionaire was completely
unreasonable for the average person
during the Gilded Age and this only
became worse during the Great Depression
but things would bounce back stronger
than anyone thought possible after World
War II the 1960s brought with the likely
the strongest economic period in U.S
history from the average person's
perspective
unemployment was consistently in the
three to five percent range and that
this is when the idea of the American
dream really started to flourish people
could come to America start a business
and become a millionaire not by the age
of 25 or something but maybe throughout
an entire lifetime
this was also likely the best time to
aim to become a millionaire it wasn't
super out there like trying to become a
billionaire but it also wasn't super
common like the average price of a
Californian house or something it was
akin to trying to make around a 10
million today which sounds about right
a hard and ambitious goal for sure but
also not too out there but this golden
age of millionaires didn't last forever
in fact it didn't even last 10 years as
the 1970s brought with it an
extraordinary amount of pain right at
the beginning of the decade president
Richard Nixon would put an end to the
Bretton Wood system aka the gold
standard this meant that US Dollars
wouldn't no longer be backed by gold
which led to much of the general public
losing trust in the dollar and as trust
plummeted it inflation skyrocketed and
this was much worse than what we saw
over the past few years back in the 70s
inflation would Peak above 10 on two
separate occasions to make things worse
the Middle Eastern countries would band
together and launch an oil strike
against America leading to one of the
worst energy crises of all time to put
things in perspective within just these
10 years the value of the dollar would
over half while the median price of a
home at nearly tripled
things were getting pretty bad and
America was in desperate need of a
change enter Ronald Reagan the landmark
of Reagan's presidency was no doubt
Reaganomics
now you can get into the weeds of all
the specifics and intricacies but in a
broad sense Reaganomics was pretty
simple essentially the idea was to make
it easier for rich people to grow their
wealth by cutting taxes and decreasing
regulation as the rich got richer some
of their wealth should naturally trickle
down to people of all classes or at
least that was the theory in practice
this turned out to be completely false
on one hand this did definitely reignite
the American dream it's obviously a lot
easier to make a million dollars when
you have to pay less in taxes and deal
with less regulation so the rich did
indeed get richer pulling along the
American economy with them the problem
though was that not much wealth actually
made its way to the average American as
the rich naturally just tended to keep
the extra money they made
if a business made an extra hundred
dollars in profit 90 would just go
straight to the owner and maybe 10 would
make its way back to the people combine
this with the fact that Reagan had to
cut down a bunch of social programs to
make Reaganomics work and suddenly the
average person was worse off than before
but despite all the pain there was a
select group of average people that were
doing better than ever before
foreign
it may seem like Tech bro is making
millions is a new phenomenon thanks to
companies like Google and Facebook and
apple but this trend can actually be
traced back to the 1990s take Dell for
example following Dell's IPO in 1988 a
whopping 2 700 millionaires would be
minted over the next 20 years in fact
Dell millionaires were so common that
people just refer to them as
billionaires and this marked the first
step of the normalization of
millionaires while 2 700 millionaires
was definitely a massive amount for a
single company back in the 90s and 2000s
compared to the overall population it's
still an extremely small amount but that
was just the beginning keep in mind many
of you tech companies that dominate The
Fortune 500 today were yet to even be
created and over the next 20 years these
companies would grow to unimaginable
scales reaching hundreds of billions if
not trillions in market cap and I know
we talk about such numbers all the time
but let's take a second to recognize
just how massive a trillion dollars is a
trillion dollars is literally a million
millions in other words a trillion
dollar company can make a million people
millionaires apple with their three
trillion dollar market cap can produce
three million millionaires Microsoft 2.7
million millionaires Google 1.5 million
millionaires Amazon 1.3 million
millionaires Nvidia 1.1 million
Millionaires and that's just the top
five companies of course none of these
companies have actually created a
million millionaires yet but what they
they have done is create hundreds of
thousands of employee and investor
millionaires each think about this 8 out
of the top 10 richest people in the
world made all of their money in Tech at
this point you could even classify
Warren Buffett as a tech billionaire
given that he owns 150 billion dollars
worth of Apple stock and I imagine that
this is the same case with most
millionaires as well the US currently
boasts a total of 22 million
millionaires most of whom made their
money in Tech and live in Tech cities
like San Francisco Seattle and Austin in
San Francisco for example you need to
almost be a multi-millionaire to even
feel financially comfortable and that's
not my opinion Charles Schwab actually
conducted a full-on study about this
they found that to be financially
comfortable in San Francisco you need a
net worth of 1.7 million dollars to be
considered wealthy you need a net worth
of 4.7 million dollars so our friend
from the beginning really wasn't
exaggerating when he said that being a
multi-millionaire very much felt like
being in a middle class at least based
in a Californian Tech City but really
it's only a matter of time until it
becomes the same case for the rest of
America as well thanks to inflation
economic growth and the text increasing
omnipresence what started off as a way
to describe the richest people on a
planet has since Fallen to be a generic
term to describe the upper middle class
at least within America and other
Western countries of course a million
dollars is still an extraordinary amount
of money outside of these countries but
that's why millionaires just don't feel
like millionaires anymore the new
measure of wealth seems to be earning a
million dollar salary check out this
video to learn about Chachi PD struggle
to pay out million dollar salaries but
until then I'm Hari and I'll see you
guys on the next one